♪
>> Sean: DAY 595 OF THE
MUELLER WITCH-HUNT AND THE
HILL'S JOHN SULEMAN OUT WITH
REPORT THAT THE RUSSIAN
INTEL KEPT SECRET.
JOHN SOLOMON REPORTING ON
RUDY GIULIANI'S MUELLER TO
BE INVESTIGATED FOR
DESTRUCTION OF FBI EVIDENCE.
RUDY GIULIANI JOINS US FOR
HANNITY WATCH TONIGHT.
WELCOME BACK.
HANNITY CHAMP SHAWN RING
THAT YOU HAVE THAT YOU
DESERVE.
MUELLER SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE, KEN
STARR AGREES WITH YOU AS
WELL.
THAT IS THE ERASED TEXT
MESSAGES OF THE LEAD
INVESTIGATORS AT THE START
OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> WELL, THIS WOULD BE A
MASSIVE SCANDAL IF IT
HAPPENED TO US.
IF IT HAPPENED -- IF WE WERE
PRODUCING DOCUMENTS FOR THEM
AND WE SAID OH, WE HAVE
19,000 TEXTS RELEVANT
PERIOD.
>> Sean: THE RELEVANT
>> THAT WE HAD ERASED.
IT WAS ERASED BY MUELLER BY
THE WAY.
ERASED BY MUELLER'S RECORD
OFFICER WHO CLAIMS THAT HE
OR SHE LOOKED AT THEM AND
THEY DON'T CONTAIN ANYTHING
PERT NEGLIGENT?
HOW CAN THAT
NEW CAN THAT
NEGLCAN THAT
NEGLIGN THAT
NEGLIGENTHAT
NEGLIGENT AT
NEGLIGENT -- PERTINENT.
THEY ARE TEXTING EVERY DAY
HOW THEY HATED TRUMP AND HOW
THEY HAD AN INSURANCE POLICY
TO GET HIM OUT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY WENT TO
WORK FOR MUELLER AND THEY
STOPPED TEXTING BACK AND
FORTH.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
WHAT MAKES SENSE TO ME IS
THERE ARE HIGHLY DAMAGING
TEXTS ABOUT THE WAY THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN AS A
COMPLETELY ILLEGITIMATE
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY DONALD
TRUMP.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION IN
SEARCH OF A CRIME AND THEY
HAVEN'T FOUND ONE YET.
COLLUSION IS NOT A CRIME.
IT'S NOT A CRIME.
>> Sean: FIRING COMEY IS NOT
A CRIME.
>> FIRING COMEY IS NOT A
CRIME.
THE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE NOT CRIMINAL.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN A
VIOLATION OF THE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW.
THEY ARE PAYING OFF A
POSSIBLE CIVIL JUDGMENT.
THIS IS MAKE UP A CRIME,
MAKE UP A CRIME.
HOPING TO FIND ONE
EVENTUALLY.
AND THEN THEY FRAME CERTAIN
PEOPLE.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO FLYNN.
WHAT THEY DID TO FLYNN WAS
OUTRAGEOUS.
THEY TOLD HIM SOMETHING HE
HUT PAPER IN HIS DRAWER.
>> Sean: BY PAPER YOU MEAN
TRANSCRIPT.
>> TRANSCRIPT.
THEY SURVEILLED HIM AND
LEAKED RAW INTELLIGENCE.
>> IF THIS WERE SEEKING
TRUTH THEY WOULD HAVE SAID
GENERAL DOES THIS REFRESH
YOUR RECOLLECTION.
I KNOW THIS GAME, I USED TO
PLAY IT A LOT MORE ETHICAL
THAN YOU DO.
>> IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN THAT
YOU HAD MCCABE SAYING YOU
DON'T NEED A LAWYER.
THEN YOU HAD THE FBI
DIRECTOR SAID OH, IT'S FOUR
DAYS INTO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FOLLOW THE NORMAL
PROCESS AND GO THROUGH THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
>> WE THINK WE CAN GET AWAY
WITH IT BECAUSE NOT
EXPERIENCED ENOUGH.
GET AWAY WITH WHAT?
GET AWAY WITH UNETHICAL
BEHAVIOR, POSSIBLY ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR.
TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
THEY WOULD BE OUTRAGED AND
DEMANDING THAT HIS CASE BE
DISMISSED JUST TO TEACH THE
PROSECUTOR A LESSON.
>> Sean: WILL HILLARY EVER
GET IN TROUBLE FOR THE
VIOLATION OF THE ESPIONAGE
ACT?
WILL SHE EVER GET IN TROUBLE
FOR DESTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
BYE DESTROYING EMAILS.
WE KNOW NOW THAT THE TOP
OFFICIALS IN THE FBI AND DOJ
LIED AND PRESENTED
UNVERIFIED.
>> RIGHT.
>> INFORMATION TO FISA COURT
JUDGES.
>> RIGHT.
THOSE FOUR AFFIDAVITS ARE
FALSE.
THEY ARE FALSE AFFIDAVITS.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF DID I THAT?
>> YOU WOULD BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND POSSIBLY
INDICTED BY NOW.
>> Sean: IF YOU ARE MY
LAWYER, COULD YOU GET ME
OFF?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
UNLESS THERE WAS AN
EXPLANATION I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT.
THE REALITY IS IT HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED AND IT'S NOT
BEING INVESTIGATE YOU HAD.
AND MUELLER HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED FOR WIPING OUT
THOSE TEXTS AT AN EXTREMELY
RELEVANT PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY SAY IT'S PART OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RETENTION
POLICY.
GARBAGE.
IT'S NOT PART OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT RETENTION POLICY
TO DESTROY EVIDENCE.
YOU CAN'T SUPERSEDE THE LAW
AND SAY PEOPLE WHO SAID
HILLARY SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO THAT
SAYS TRUMP VOTERS HE COULD
SMELL BECAUSE OF SMELLY
WALMART PEOPLE.
THAT HAD AN INSURANCE POLICY
AND MEDIA LEAKED STRATEGY.
HERE IS THE MENTALITY, I
KNOW KNOW THESE PEOPLE.
I KNEW THEM WHEN I WAS
MAYOR.
I KNEW THEM BEFORE I WAS
I GREW UP IN A LIBERAL CITY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ON A MORAL
HIGH GRAND.
THEY CAN JUSTIFY ANY MEANS
FOR THEIR END, WHICH IS TO
SAVE THE COUNTRY FROM DONALD
TRUMP AND PUT US IN THE
HANDS OF HILLARY CLINTON OR
SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> Sean: HERE'S A QUESTION.
DO YOU SEE A DAY WHERE
HILLARY IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE,
THOSE WHO SIGN THOSE
FIRESTONE FISA WARRANTS IS
IN TROUBLE.
COMEY IS IN TROUBLE.
MCCABE IS IN TROUBLE
LEGALLY.
LISA PAGE AND STRZOK, ARE
THEY EVER GOING TO GET IN
TROUBLE?
EVERYTHING YOU ARE
DESCRIBING IS MORE SERIOUS
THAN ANY CRIME THEY HAVE
LOOKED AT.
PRIFER REAL CRIMES.
THEY ARE ASKING FOR NO TIME
IN JAIL FOR FLYNN.
HOW KEY HAVE BEEN TREATIES.
THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT ASKING
FOR TIME IN JAIL-TIME?
>> WHEN DOES IT END.
>> IT ENDS WHEN HE FILES HIS
REPORT.
>> Sean: WILL THERE BE A
GIULIANI REPORT.
>> DAMN RIGHT THERE BE WITH
A GIULIANI REPORT.
IT WILL BE THE TRUTH.